welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
today we take you to The Cutting Edge
world of Robotics where Innovation knows
no bounds in this tutorial video we
embark on an accelerating Journey
Through the top 10 robotic projects that
are pushing the boundaries of technology
and human Ingenuity from autonomous
drones mapping Uncharted territories to
humanoid robots mimicking human
movements
these projects represent the Forefront
of mechanical and artificial
intelligence advancements whether you
are a robotics Enthusiast a tech
afficianado or simply curious about the
future join us as we dwell into the
Realms of innovation Automation and
extraordinary Creations that are
reshaping our world buckle up for a
captivating exploration of the most
remarkable robotic Endeavors in the 21st
century but before we begin if these are
the type of videos you'd like to watch
then like share sh and hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
get notified if you are a professional
with minimum one year of experience and
an aspiring artificial intelligence
professional looking for online training
and certifications from the prestigious
universities in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learns postgraduate program and
artificial intelligence from P
University in collaboration with IBM is
just what you need for more details head
straight to our homepage and and search
for artificial intelligence and machine
learning postgraduate program from Pur
University or simply click on the link
in the description box below now without
further delay over to our training so
now we will get started with the top 10
robotic projects for 2024 so the first
one in the list is face recognition
robot face recognition robot is
incredibly resourceful and has vast
potential for numerous applications
making it a significant player in the
field of Robotics and AI this project
equipped with Advanced facial
recognition technology offers
multifaceted benefits it can enhance
security systems automate access control
and even personalized user experiences
in sectors like healthcare it can help
identify patients and access their
medical records swiftly moreover in
detail it can improve customer service
and shopping experiences the
applications extend to autonomous
vehicles Public Safety and Beyond the
future scope for professionals with
expertise in face recognition reports is
promising the increasing demand for
security and privacy along with growing
Reliance on automation ensures that this
technology will continue to evolve and
expand into various Industries job
opportunities include roles in research
and development software engineering
data analysis system integration and
project management the next project in
the list is fire extinguishing robot one
fascinating robotic project and and
extinguish fires in hazardous
environments these robots are equipped
with Advanced sensors cameras and fire
suppression systems when deployed in
scenarios such as industrial plans or
buildings they can quickly identify
fires and access the situation and apply
the fire suppressants without risking
human lives the future scope for this
project is promising as Industries and
urban spaces continue to grow the risk
of fire incidents remains significant
fire extinguishing r robots offer a
safer and more efficient approach to
Fire Control these robots can be
integrated into Smart City
infrastructure industrial facilities and
other disaster Management systems with
advancements in Ai and Robotics we can
expect enhanced capabilities such as
improv navigation and complex
environments and the ability to
collaborate with human firefighters in
terms of job opportunities this project
opens doors to various roles in robotics
artificial intelligence and a automation
there will be a demand for robot
designers software Engineers maintenance
technicians and professionals
specializing in Ai and machine learning
for robot autonomy additionally jobs
related to the development and
deployment of safety focused
Technologies are likely to grow offering
exciting career prospects on fire safety
and disaster management proceeding ahead
the next one in the list is phone
operated Land Rover a phone operated
Land Rover often referred to as a remote
control or teleoperated Land Rover is an
Innovative robotic project that combines
the versatility of Land Rover with
remote control capabilities via a
smartphone or any internet enabl device
such a project can serve various
practical purposes from exploration and
surveillance in challenging terrains to
remote operations in Industries like
agriculture construction or even
disaster management it can also be used
for recreational purposes in remote
controlled C races or as a hobbyist
project the future scope of this project
is promising with the advancement in 5G
technology low latency communication is
becoming more accessible making remote
operation of this Vehicles more
efficient and responsible this
technology can revolutionalize
industries by reducing the need for
human presence in hazardous environments
and providing cost-effective solution
for remote monitoring and operations in
terms of job opportunities professionals
who special Iz in the development and
management of remotely operated Vehicles
like phone operated Land Rovers are in
high demand carrier prospects may
include roles in robotic engineering
teleoperation system development
autonomous vehicle operation and even
entrepreneurship operations and
opportunities for those who wish to
create solutions for various Industries
as technology continues to advance the
future looks bright for individuals
skilled in this field now next ahead we
have human detection robot one
intriguing robot Project based on human
detection is the development of advanced
human detection robots these robots are
equipped with sophisticated sensors
computer vision and artificial
intelligence algorithms enabling them to
identify and interact with humans in a
variety of settings they have
applications in diverse Fields such as
health care security and customer
service for instance in healthcare they
can assist nurses by monitoring patients
and delivering medication improving
patient care and reducing the workload
on medical staff in security human
detection robots can Patrol areas detect
unauthorized intrusions and Alert
security Personnel the future scope for
this technology is promising with
ongoing advancements in Ai and Robotics
the demand for human detection robots is
expected to rise job opportunities will
expand the areas of robot development
programming maintenance and deployment
robotic Engineers AI Specialists and
technicians will find a growing demand
for their skills additionally human
robot interaction experts and
professionals who can adapt these robots
for specific Industries will play a
crucial role in continue to development
and deployment of human detection robots
as these robots become more integrated
into our daily lives the potential for
career growth and innovation in this
field is substantial moving ahead we
have metal detection robot one notable
robotic project is the metal detection
robot this specialized robot is equipped
with sensors and Technology to detect
various metal objects it finds
applications in a wide range of sectors
including security industrial settings
and even archaeological Expeditions the
future scope of medical detection robots
looks promising they can be further
enhanced with Advanced artificial
intelligence and machine learning
algorithms enabling them to distinguish
between different types of metals and
objects with greater Precision in
security these robots can play a crucial
role in detecting concealed weapons or
Contraband items in Industries they can
streamline quality control processes by
identifying metal defects in
manufacturing as the need for Automation
and improved safety measures grows metal
detection robots are likely to play a
pivotal role in various sectors the job
opportunities for this particular field
are first one robotic engineer designing
and developing metal detection robots
including hardware and software
components second one is robotics
technician who handles the maintenance
repair and troubleshooting of these
robots third one is AI and machine
learning specialist who is responsible
for enhancing the robotics detection
capabilities through advanced algorithms
fourth one is security specialist who is
responsible for implementing metal
detection robots for security and
surveillance applications fifth one is
quality control analyst using these
robots in manufacturing to ensure
product quality the future job market
for professionals skilled in metal
detection robots is promising offering
diverse opportunities in technology
security manufacturing and much more
next ahead we have Hospital sanitizing
robot one notable robotic project in the
field of healthcare is the development
of Hospital sanitizing robots these
autonomous robots are equipped with
Advanced sensors AI technology and UVC
light to to disinfect hospital rooms and
services and surfaces ensuring a sterile
and safe environment for patients and
healthc Care Professionals they can
navigate independently through Hospital
corridors detect areas in need of
disinfection and efficiently eliminate
harmful pathogens including bacteria and
viruses the future scope for Hospital
sanitizing robots is promising the
ongoing emphasis on infection control
and Hospital hygiene particularly in
light of the coid 19 pandemic highlights
the growing demand for automated
sanitization Solutions as Healthcare
facilities increasingly adopt these
robots there will be substantial
opportunities for Professionals in
various Fields job roles may include
robotic Engineers AI specialist
maintenance technicians and Healthcare
administrators specializing in
implementation of these Technologies
moreover the continued evolution of this
technology will likely lead to further
advancements creating job prospects and
research development and Innovation
within the healthcare robotics sector
next ahead we have brain controlled
robotic arm one fascinating robotic
project is the development of brain
controlled robotic arms these Innovative
systems bridge the gap between the human
mind and machine allowing individuals to
control a robotic arm through their
thoughts and Ural signals the technology
involves Advanced EEG that is
electroencephalography or invasive brain
implants to to capture and interpret
brain signals translating them into
precise movements of the robotic arm
such technology holds immense promise in
enhancing the quality of life for
individuals with Mobility impairments
enabling them to regain Independence and
perform daily tasks the future scope for
brain control robotic arms is extensive
as the technology matures it can find
applications in medical Fields like
neuro rehabilation providing therapeutic
assistance to patients with paralysis
moreover it could be utilized in
Industries requiring delicate and
precise tasks such as manufacturing or
surgery this project opens doors to
carriers in robotic engineering
neuroscience and human machine interface
development job opportunities may
include roles like neuroscientists
robotic Engineers software developers
and medical device Specialists creating
a promising and more impactful future
for Professionals in these fields moving
ahead we have physiotherapy robot one of
the promising robotic project in the
field of physiotherapy is the
development of rehabilation robots these
robots are designed to assist
physiotherapists in providing precise
and personalized rehabilation programs
for patients recovering from injuries or
surgeries they offer a wide range of
therapeutic exercises monitor patient
progress and can even adjust the
intensity of exercises based on the
patients abilities the future scope for
physiotherapy reports is increasing
incredibly and it is promising as the
global population ages the demand for
rehabilation services is increasing
these robots have the potential to
bridge the gap between the demand for
Physiotherapy and the availability of
trained professionals additionally
advancements in artificial intelligence
and machine learning enable these robots
to adapt and personalize therapy making
rehabilation more effective job
opportunities in this field are
expanding physiotherapy clinics
hospitals and and Healthcare
institutions will require professionals
who can operate and manage these reports
there will be also a need for individual
skilled in robot maintenance and
software development to ensure the
smooth functioning of these devices
moreover as the technology evolves there
will be opportunities for researchers
and Engineers to further enhance the
capabilities of physiotherapy reports
overall this project represents an
exciting intersection of healthcare and
Robotics with significant po potential
for career growth and improving patient
outcomes next the ninth one in the list
is amphibious robot one fascinating
robotic project is the development of
amphibus to operate seamlessly in both
Aquatic and terrestrial environments
these robots serve a variety of purposes
including environmental monitoring
search and rescue missions and
underwater inspections the future scope
for apibus robots is promising as
climate change impacts sea levels and
intensifies natural disaster ERS these
reports are increasingly valuable for
tasks such as flood assessment and
rescue missions they can also be used in
Environmental Research and monitor the
health of aquatic ecosystems with
advancements in Ai and sensor technology
amphibious robots can become more
autonomous and adaptable expanding their
range of applications some of the major
job opportunities in this particular
field are robotics engineer as the field
of Robotics continues to grow there will
be demand for engineers who specialize
in designing and building amphibious
robots next is environmental scientist
professionals can use these robots to
collect data on Maran EOS systems and
climate change impacts third one is
search and rescue specialist amphibious
robots can play a crucial role in
Disaster Response and search and rescue
operations fourth one is robot operator
and technician individuals will be
needing to operate maintain and repair
these robots lastly software developer
skilled programmers will be essential to
develop and refine find the software
that controls the robot movements and
data analysis capabilities the future of
amphibious robots holds promise not only
in terms of technological advancement
but also in the creation of various job
opportunities across different sectors
making a compelling area of study and
specialization for those interested in
robotics and environmental Sciences
lastly we have the electronic skin or
also known as e skin one fascinating
robotic project centered around
electronic skin is the development of e
skin or electronic skin electronic skin
is a flexible thin and highly sensitive
material that can mimic the Tactical and
temperature sensing capabilities of
human skin it is embedded in various
sensors allowing robots and prosthetic
limb to feel the environment data
providing valuable data for navigation
object manipulation and safety the
future scope for electronic skin
technology is immense as Robotics and
artificial intelligence continue to
advance electronic scale will play a
pivotal role in enhancing the
interaction between machines and their
surroundings it has applications in
medical robotics enabling more delicate
and precise surgeries and in prosthetic
lymphs giving users a more natural and
intuitive experience and in prosthetic
lymphs giving users some more natural
and intuitive experience furthermore
it's crucial in Industrial Automation
for task like quality control where
robots need to handle fragile and
sensitive items job opportunities in
this field include roles like electronic
skin Engineers robotic developers sensor
integration Specialists and research
scientists these professionals work on
designing developing and improving
electronic skin technology making it a
promising area for those interested in
robotics and Material Science the demand
for skilled individuals in this field is
expected to grow significantly as
electronic skin becomes more integral to
the robotics industry and with that we
have reached to the end of this session
on top 10 robotic projects for 2024
should you need any assistance PB or
other resources used in this session
please do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
we'll be more than happy to help you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you for watching and keep learning stay
tuned for more from Simply learn staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to to Career Success click the link
in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here